[Music]
you are married to the lovely Melissa
McCarthy yes I am yes I am and I have to
say oh when I that you you had these
scenes together in bridesmaids that got
a lot of people talking where you're on
a plane and and and I love those those
moments between the two of you right
then for anyone who's stuck around for
the end of the movie there is a few
people that did ya know who stayed I
think was it after the credits I think
or it was like there was a little fake
end and then right bang and then bang
you did a you guys had a sex scene
together yeah and do you want to should
we show it first or talk about it first
uh what is how let's show it first and
then I can walk you through what
happened let's take a look at this clip
from bridesmaids really new exciting
food stuff I'm worn out I'm gonna go
lather up kind of shower up and do it
all over again
[Applause]
first of all it gave me a lot of ideas
for my life with that sandwich thing but
what you did not know that that was
gonna be in the movie when that was shot
you weren't sure no no no I did not know
Melissa she called me up and said hey
can you get to set really quick and I
say you know I'm not working today today
I don't think she said no I think you I
think you could be and I said okay so
over lunch I Drive down to the Sony lot
and I go in to see Melissa who was there
and Annie
mama lo a writer and the producer is
holding sandwiches and I'm like so hey
guys what's going on and they go Moses's
hey be cool be cool just put this on and
I'm like in it's a it's a it's a robe
it's like one of her robes I'm like why
am i putting that on she's just just be
cool just be cooled you can cool put
this on and it's it's like lady's
Underpants and I'm like when people tell
you be cool it usually means something
bad and yeah yeah and you know so next
thing I know I'm in Judd Apatow's
trailer and apparently he had like he
didn't know that much about it but he'd
authorized it
he'd authorized there was like this
covert kind of mission that happened
over a lunch hour and so the next thing
I know I've got turkey meat on my
nipples yeah and Melissa is like
flicking it and flicking it and you know
the guy no one's laughing right you know
cuz and I'm just like you're alone in
this trailer where this very strange
scene is playing out yeah I felt like a
weird sex offender but uh but I was with
my why you know so then I just I was
like what is this gonna be for like the
internet or something they're like yeah
they'll never use it in the movie this
will never so then you're sitting at a
screening and the movies over and then
bang and I'm sitting next to Melissa's
mom yeah oh right
and I full screen you in women's
underwear yeah and then what's eating
that sandwich I'm just like hey sorry
sandy yeah that's what happens